PROFESSOR: All right.
Lecture 17 was about folding
polygons into polyhedra,
and today we will do it
with real pieces of paper.
But before we get
there, I want to talk
about some things we could make.
In lecture, I demonstrated
this perimeter having technique
where you take
any convex polygon
and you pick any point
on the perimeter.
Then you measure out the
perimeter halfway on each side.
You get the antipodal point, y.
And then just
glue-- locally, you
glue everything
around x and around y.
So I mean, you just start.
We call this zipping where you
don't glue any extra material
in here, you just start
zipping these guys together.
I guess these circles or when
you happen to hit this vertex,
well, then you just keep
going-- zip, zip, zip, zip, zip.
So that's one thing we could
make with convex polygons.
Slightly more general
is called a pita form.
This is defined in the textbook.
And the idea is instead
of a convex polygon,
you could take any convex body.
It could have some corners
or it could be smooth.
So this is what
we call a convex,
or what I'm going to call
today a convex 2D body, meaning
it can be smooth in
addition to polygonal.
And then you pick any
point on the boundary
and you measure out the
perimeter halfway, x and y,
and you glue in
exactly the same way.
Now, it does not follow
from Alexandrov's theorem
that this will make
a convex thing,
but it follows from a
slightly more general form
of Alexandrov's theorem called
Alexandrov-Pogorelov theorem.
So Pogorelov was a
student of Alexandrov
and he edited some things
that Alexandrov wrote,
but then also Pogorelov
wrote his own papers
and proved some
stronger versions
of Alexandrov's theorem that
hold for smooth bodies, not
just polygonal folding.
So Alexandrov's
theorem, you recall,
if you have a convex
polyhedral metric homeomorphic
to a sphere, then it's realized
by a unique convex polyhedron.
So the Pogorelov's extension
is that if you have everything
except the polyhedral
part-- so if you
have a convex metric
homeomorphic to a sphere-- so
topologically it's a sphere,
but we omit the polyhedral part.
So polyhedral was that you
have finitely many vertices.
In some sense, I have
infinitely many vertices,
infinitesimal curvature
at every point here.
Then it's realized by a
unique convex 3D body.
So same concept of
a convex object.
Well, I should say this
is really the surface of.
So a convex body, I should
probably define that.
Convex body is one where
you take any two points
and you draw a
straight line and you
stay within the body for
the entire straight line.
So that's convex.
You take any two points,
like this one and this one,
draw a line between them,
and you stay inside.
The body is the piece of
paper we're gluing up.
Here we have a 3D
body, but then we
just look at the surface
of it, the boundary.
And that's going to be
the surface we make.
Technically, that
surface is not convex.
It's the interior that's convex
because you can draw lines
through it and you stay inside.
This is exactly the same thing,
but instead of polyhedron here,
we have body because we didn't
have finitely many vertices.
And I'm not going to
prove this theorem.
But existence is
basically the same proof.
You just take a limit.
So you can polygonalize
with lots of little edges
here, add little points,
and take the limit
as that approximation gets very,
very close to the actual curve.
At all times you
have a polyhedron,
it's easy to show you will
converge to a convex body.
The uniqueness is the
harder part, I believe.
I haven't read the proof,
but it was more challenging.
I think that took 20 years
or so to settle uniqueness.
Alexandrov's like 1950.
This theorem I think is
1973 the final version.
But the version without unique
was proved back in 1950.
So that's something
else we can do.
Instead of cutting
out a polygon,
we can cut out a nice smooth
thing or you can add some kinks
and be smooth elsewhere.
As long as it's
convex, then you're
guaranteed that-- we're
only gluing together
two convex points.
It could be flat or it
could be strictly convex,
which means we'll have at most
360 degrees of material at any
point because it's always
doing two at most 180's.
And so we will have
a convex metric,
meaning always at most 360
of material everywhere.
So then this theorem applies
so we'll get a unique thing.
Another thing we could
make is called a D-form.
And I have some examples
of D-forms here.
So the idea with the D-form is
you take two convex 2D bodies--
so here they have some
straight parts and some curve
parts-- of the same perimeter.
I pick one point from one
body and I pick another point
from the other body.
I attach them there.
And then I zip.
So it would be zip,
zip, zip, zip, zip.
Wherever my fingers
were at the same time,
those are points that
get glued together.
And this is with the
convex body you get.
Again, Alexandrov-Pogorelov
applies because we're still
only gluing two convex
points together at any point.
As long as these guys
have matching perimeter,
we'll be OK.
And so we will get a
unique convex 3D body.
In this case, we get
this fun kind of shape.
So this is what I
suggest you make.
D-forms tend to look a
little bit cooler somehow
because they have two polygons.
And the one that's
particularly easy to build
is two copies of the
same shape, but then you
don't want to glue
corresponding points.
Like if I glued this
point to that point,
I would just get a flat,
doubly covered thing
and that's boring.
But you just pick
some other point
and glue it to
non-matching points,
then it acts like you have
two very different convex
bodies which is kind of cool.
I have some images
of D-forms here.
There's actually a whole book
on D-forms by John Sharp.
They're invented by this guy
Tony Wills who's an artist.
At the top, the
quote is, "there is
no such thing as
an ugly D-form."
So we are guaranteed
success here.
And also it says, "they
surprise, confuse,
can be addictive.
They're an intellectual virus.
Beware."
So you've been warned.
This is Tony Wills,
the inventor.
Now, from the
artistic perspective,
you don't have to start
from convex polygons.
We're going to start
from convex bodies
because they're
guaranteed to work.
If you're careful to satisfy
Alexandrov-Pogorelov,
you can have a convex
metric even though you
start from nonconvex bodies,
although in this case,
he's actually getting
nonconvex shapes as well.
More typical D-form is
something like this.
This is made from two ellipses
and he builds them out
of metal.
This is a simulation by
this guy Kenneth Brakke
who has this software
called Surface Evolver.
And it's usually used for
computing minimal services,
soap bundles and
things like that.
But here it's computing
what D-forms look like,
approximately.
And so this is an example
of taking two ellipses
and instead of-- if you
glue at matching points,
they would be flat-- but
then you change the rotation.
So here, they're rotated by 22.5
degrees, rotated by 45 degrees,
rotated by 90 degrees, so
you get this nice continuum
of different things that
you could zip together.
So I propose we make some.
And so you have your
scissors and tape.
If you don't have two sheets of
paper, get some from the front.
And so everyone have
scissors, tape, everything?
We're going to have
to share a bit.
So what we want to do is make
two identical convex shapes.
So you have some here.
Two rectangles are
valid convex shapes.
You could cut not all.
Everyone should do
something different.
I'm just going to make sure
they're nicely aligned.
Hold on tight because you
don't want them to let go,
and then just cut.
Always turn left
with your cutting.
You can be smooth.
You can have some corners,
what you want to do.
Just always turn left.
And once you have your two
shapes, you pull them apart.
Make sure you do not glue
corresponding points.
Pick some other points and
attach them together with tape.
Here's where it gets a
little bit challenging.
With smooth curves, it's little
harder to tape them together,
so you're probably going to
have to use a bunch of points
of tape, so to speak,
not literal points.
And I just tape, tape, tape.
Before you get all
the way, you want
to make sure you can still
pop it up and be convex.
I think we'll be able to
do that by [INAUDIBLE]
inside the limit.
Give me some scissors.
All right.
There's my D-form.
Mostly convex, kind of fun.
So a funny thing you'll
notice about D-forms,
if you made yours
smooth-- so if you don't
have any kinks on the
outer boundary-- then
the surface looks smooth,
which is kind of nice.
The other thing is there's
this noticeable seam where
you taped things.
There, you're not
smooth, obviously.
You've got a crease
along the seam.
But also it looks like all
that the surface is doing
is kind of taking
the convex hull,
the envelope of that seam.
So there's two
properties we observe.
One is that it looks
smooth, except at the seam.
And the other is
that the hull surface
is the convex hull
of the 3D seam.
And I want to prove
both of those things.
Those are both true facts.
But first I need to
define some things.
So we're going to
prove that D-forms
are smooth and
other good things.
This is a paper
that was originally
a class project in this
class, I think in 2007.
Sounds about right.
Submitted during class, it looks
like, or just after semester
with Greg Price.
D-form have no spurious creases.
So what's a D-form?
You take two, for
us, it's going to be
two convex shapes
of equal perimeter.
You glue two points, two
corresponding points P and Q
together, and then
you zip from there.
We can actually talk about
something even more general
which we'll call a seam form.
A seam form, you can have
multiple convex shapes.
It's a little harder
to imagine, but you
can join multiple
points together.
Maybe you join all three
of those corners together.
As long as you have at most
360 of material everywhere,
it'll be fine.
Maybe do some zipping.
I'm not going to try to figure
out exactly how this gluing
pattern works, but you
find a gluing pattern
where you don't
violate anything.
So it looks like
if I do this one,
I better have these
guys also a little bit
sharp so that they don't add
up to too much angle there.
So these three points
would also join together.
This would be like three
petals in like a seed pod
or something, like those leaves
that wrap around little fruits
or something.
I won't try to draw it but--
I guess I will try to draw it.
Something like this.
So that's a thing.
This could even fold
not exactly a sphere,
but something like a sphere.
So seam forms, you could have
any number of convex shapes
and glue them together
however you want,
provided at all points you
satisfy Alexandrov-Pogorelov,
so you only have at most
360 degrees of material
and you are
topologically a sphere.
Then you have a seam form.
So most of the theorems I'm
going to talk about apply
to general seam forms, but we're
interested in D-forms and pita
forms in particular.
So let me tell you some
theorems about seam forms.
Theorem 1 is that
a seam form equals
convex hull of its seams.
So the seams in
general are these parts
where you did gluing,
wherever you taped stuff.
The boundaries of the convex
polygons, those are the seams.
They map to some curves in 3D.
If you take the
convex hull, the claim
is you get the entire seam form.
That's actually
pretty easy to prove.
Then the second
claim is there aren't
many creases other than
the seams of course.
The seams are usually
going to be creased.
And these creases are
going to be line segments.
And not just any line
segments, but their endpoints
are pretty special.
So the claim is that
the creases have
to be line segments basically
connecting strict vertices.
What do I mean by strict vertex?
Something like these three
points which come together,
provided the total angle here
is strictly less than 360.
I call that a strict vertex.
Whereas these points
connecting from here to here,
those don't count
as strict vertices.
They do have curvature, but
only infinitesimal curvature.
Because this is essentially
180 degrees of material,
just slightly less
because it's curved.
So only where I have
kinks can I potentially
have strictly less than 180.
And if I join them together
to be strictly less than 360,
that's a strict vertex.
So potentially, I have a
seam coming from here, also
at the other endpoint.
So in this picture, I might
have a crease like this,
I might have a
crease like this, I
might have a crease
like this, potentially.
But in something like a D-form,
there are no strict vertices.
If these are smooth-- so I'll
assume here these are smooth.
We could call it a smooth
D-form if you like.
Then there's no vertices,
no strict vertices,
only these sort of
barely vertices.
So there could be no creases.
There's one other
situation which
is creases could be
tangent to seams.
This should seem
impossible because the way
I've defined things
it is impossible.
You're tangent to a seam, that
would be you're like this.
How am I supposed to have
a crease inside that's
tangent to the seam?
The answer is you can't.
If these regions are
convex, you can't have them.
This statement is actually
about a more general form
of seam forms where you
can have a nonconvex piece.
So in general seam form, you
have a bunch of flat pieces
and you somehow search
for them together so
that you satisfy
Alexandrov-Pogorelov.
And now you could
have a tangent.
I could, for example, have a
crease that emanates from there
or have a crease that
emanates from there.
But right now, it
has nowhere to stop.
The only way for these
creases to actually exist
is if there's a
kink here, then this
could go from there to there.
So this is starting at a
vertex and ending tangent.
You could, of course, also
start tangent and end tangent
if there's another bend.
But the claim is,
all crease look
like that, which
means if you carefully
designed your thing
or vaguely carefully
such as a smooth
D-form, then you're
guaranteed there are no creases
which is what we observe.
So this is justifying our
intuition from these examples.
One other case is the pita form.
So pita form does
actually make vertices.
This point x is going to be
a strict vertex because it
has less than 180 of
material, so definitely
strictly less than 360.
Same with y.
So pita form is
potentially going
to have a seam from x
to y, but that's it.
Sorry, a crease from x to y.
It has at most one crease.
I think most examples
we've made do
have such a crease from x to y.
Let's prove these theorems,
or at least sketch the proofs.
Don't want to get
too technical here.
So to prove the first
part that the seam form is
convex hull of its seams, it's
helpful to have a tool here
which is a theorem by Minkowski.
We'll call it
Minkowski's theorem,
although he has a bunch.
Hermann Minkowski.
It relates convex
things to convex hulls.
It says, any convex
body is the convex hull
of its extreme points.
What are extreme points?
Extreme points are points
on the surface where
you can touch just that
point with a tangent plane.
So if you think of
polyhedra, these
are vertices of the polyhedra.
But I want to handle
things that are smooth,
so they may might not
really have any vertices.
In general, I have
some convex body.
If I can draw-- imagine
this is in two dimensions--
if I can draw a
tangent plane that just
touches at a single point,
then I call that point extreme.
Let's look at an example here.
Here I believe
every seam point is
going to be an extreme
point because I
can put a tangent plane.
It just touches at that point.
What am I distinguishing from?
Well, for example, this point,
this surface is developable.
We know it's ruled.
So there's a straight line here.
You can see it in the
shadow, in the silhouette.
If I said, is this
point extreme?
I try to put a tangent
plane on, the only way
to get a tangent plane is
to include this entire line.
So it's impossible to
just hit this point
or any point along that line.
In fact, every interior
point, I claim,
you cannot just hit that point.
You've got to hit
an entire line.
Whereas at the
seam, I can do it.
I can angle between
this and this.
There's a tangent
plane, because this
is curving, that only
hits at one point.
If I had a straight
segment, then
the endpoints of the
straight segment of the seam
would be extreme, but the points
in the middle of the segment
would not be extreme.
So that's the
meaning of extreme.
And we're going to
use this because I
claim that these interior
points can never be extreme.
It can only be the seam
points that are extreme.
And therefore, we are the
convex hull of the seam points
because we are the convex
hull of the extreme points.
How do we argue that?
So I claim an extreme
point can't be locally flat
and at the same time be convex,
because convex in 3D, that's
what we need.
If you had a point and it
just meets a tangent plane
at that single point,
that means locally
you're kind of going
down from that plane,
if you think of that
plane as vertical.
So this is a situation.
I want to prove this.
To prove it, I need to
introduce another tool which
is a generally good
thing for you guys
to know about, so
kind of an excuse
to tell you about the Gauss
sphere, which I don't think we
actually cover in lectures,
but might come up again.
Gauss sphere is a simple idea.
For every tangent
plane-- let's just think
of this single point.
I want to look at the-- it's
called the tangent space.
Look at all the tangent
planes that touch this point.
Because this
particular tangent plan
I drew only touches that one
point, it has some wiggle room.
I can pick any direction
and just wiggle
and rotate the plane
around this point
and it won't immediately
hit the surface.
I've got a little bit of time
before it hits the surface.
So there's a two-dimensional
space of tangent planes
that touch just this point.
Because there's
at least one, I've
got to have some wiggle room.
So I want to draw that space.
And a clean way to draw the
space is for every such plane
to draw a normal vector
perpendicular to the plane,
take the direction of
that normal vector,
and draw it on a sphere.
It's a unit sphere.
So this is a sphere.
This one looks pretty vertical
so that would correspond
to the north pole of the sphere.
So that direction becomes
a point on the sphere.
Think of it as this vector
from the center of the sphere
to the north pole.
But we'll just
draw it as a point.
And because I've got a
two-dimensional space
of maneuverability or
rotatability of this plane,
I'm going to get some
region-- which maybe I
should draw like
this-- of the sphere.
Those are all the
possible normal vectors
of tangent planes at that point.
So this is called the Gauss map
where you map all these normals
to the Gauss sphere, which Gauss
sphere is just a unit sphere.
Fun fact.
The area of that thing,
which is the map of all
the tangent normal directions,
equals the curvature
at that point.
You may recall at
some point curvature
is actually Gaussian
curvature, so that's
why Gauss is all
over the place here.
Now because I claim this
is a two-dimensional space,
this thing will
have positive area.
Therefore, at this
point, that vertex
has positive curvature
on the surface.
And yet, it was supposed
to be in the middle of one
of these flat shapes.
That's supposed to
have zero curvature.
Contradiction.
Or stated more
positively, if I have
a point that is
an extreme point,
it's only touched by
one of these planes,
I have this flexibility.
Therefore, I get area.
Therefore, it is
not locally flat,
so it must be a seam point.
It could be one like this
where I'm barely non-flat,
but I am non-flat.
There's kind of
infinitesimal curvature here.
Or it could be one of these
points where I'm very non-flat,
or I guess X and Y here
are other examples of here
I'm very not flat.
I've only got 180 degrees
of curvature roughly.
So it's got to be one
of those if you're
going to be an extreme point.
Therefore, all the extreme
points are seam points.
Therefore, convex hull
of the extreme points
is the convex hull of the seams,
and that is your seam form.
So that's part one.
It's pretty easy.
Let me tell you about part two.
Part two builds on part one.
It's one reason
why we care about.
So part two is that there
are no spurious creases.
Unless you have strict
vertices, then you
could connect those up.
So let's look at a
locally flat crease point.
Actually, at this point,
I should probably mention.
This paper, I think of as a
forerunner to the "How Paper
Folds Between
Creases" paper which
is that hyperbolic
parabolas don't exist.
You may recall there were
theorems about what creases
look like, what ruled
surfaces look like,
and so on between creases.
In that setting, we've proved
things like straight creases
stay straight and all
these good things.
Here, it's a little
bit different
because we have kind of
two levels of creases.
There's the seam
which is special.
And then we're imagining
hypothetical creases
between the seam.
And could you have
a curved crease?
Claim is no.
Claim is all the creases
in between the seams
have to be straight.
And in fact, they
can't look like this.
They have to be at
corners somehow.
So that's what we're
going to prove.
But a lot of the
same techniques,
most of the same definitions.
This paper was
kind of a warm up,
I feel like, for
the nonexistence
of hyperbolic parabolas.
Although they use a
lot of the same tools.
They have two of
the same authors,
but there's no
theorem that really
is shared between the two.
They're not identical.
So we're looking
inside a flat region.
We're imagining, let's
look at a crease point.
It lies on some crease locally.
And it's a fold crease.
So I'm going to wave
my hands a little bit.
But imagine a folded crease.
Maybe it's a curve.
We don't know.
It's folded by some
angle, some nonzero angle.
Otherwise, it's not a crease.
So locally, it looks like
two kind of planes, at least
to the first order they're
going to be planes.
Maybe something like this.
I'm going to draw
the creases straight
because to the first
order, it is straight.
But it might be slightly curved.
So we're looking
at a point here.
And my point is, it's
bent by some angle.
So I'm going to draw
the two tangent planes.
There's a tangent
plane on the right.
Whatever the surface
is doing on the right,
there's a tangent
plane over there.
Whatever the surface is doing
on the left of the crease,
there's a tangent plane there.
They're not the same plane
because we are creased.
Whatever the crease
angle is, that's
the angle between
these two planes.
I want to look at this tangent
space again a little bit.
You can think of it,
the tangent space
at the least it has
this tangent plane.
For this point, you have
at least this tangent plane
and at least this
other tangent plane.
And so in particular, you have
to have the sweep between them.
So you get at least a
one-dimensional set there.
Now, this can happen.
So we're not going to
get a contradiction.
We're not going to
suddenly discover
there's a two-dimensional area
and get that it wasn't flat.
But at least we've got
a one-dimensional arc.
On the Gaussian sphere here,
we've got something like this
so far.
This is one extreme
tangent plane on the left.
This is extreme tangent
plane on the right.
These two points
correspond to those two.
And then we've got
the arc of-- you
can sweep the tangent
plane around and still
stay outside the surface,
Well, that's interesting.
It's interesting because
all of those tangent planes
share a line, which is going to
be this line that I drew here.
I mean, you look at
these two planes,
there's a line that they share.
And if you rotate the
plane through that line,
you'll still pass
through this point
and you won't hit the surface.
So in fact, all those tangent
planes share this line.
I think we actually
just need these two.
So if you don't see
that, don't worry.
There are these two planes.
There's a line there.
They're tangent,
which means that line
is on or outside the surface
because tangent planes don't
hit the surface.
I mean, they touch
the surface barely,
but they don't go interior.
Well, I claim that in fact the
surface must touch this line.
I claim the surface,
at least locally,
has got to follow
along that intersection
line of the left and
right tangent planes.
Why?
It comes down to this
Gaussian sphere thing.
We know that the surface
lies inside these two planes.
There's this wedge here.
The surface must be below.
We also know the surface comes
and touches it at this point.
Could it, from here, kind of
dip down away from this line?
I claim no.
If it dipped down, then there'd
be a third tangent plane.
The tangent plane could
follow and dip down as well.
And then we've got not
just a one-dimensional arc,
but we're actually going to get
a whole triangle in the Gauss
sphere.
Once you have a whole triangle,
that means you weren't flat.
You have positive curvature.
So we're looking at a
locally flat crease point
somewhere in the middle
of one of these polygons.
So in fact, you can't afford
to dip down because then you'd
have at least a little
bit of curvature there.
Because you have zero curvature,
you've got to stay straight.
So that means that
the surface locally
has to exist along the
segment in both directions
until something happens.
Now, we assumed
that our point was
locally flat and a crease point.
So the surface must
continue in this direction
until we reach a point that
is either not locally flat
or not a crease point.
I claim it's got to
remain a crease point.
Because look, you're following
along this intersection
line of these two
tangent planes.
These remain tangent planes.
These are not only tangent
planes at this point.
They're also tangent
planes at this point
and potentially any
point along this segment.
As long as the surface is
here, they are tangent planes.
Therefore, you are creased here.
I mean, you can't be
smooth if you're butting up
against these two
tangent planes.
So crease must be preserved, so
the only issue is locally flat.
It could be at some point
you become not locally flat.
And that indeed happens.
That's when you hit the seam.
When you hit the seam, then
you're no longer locally flat.
So this proves the
creases must be
line segments between
two points on the seam.
There's a little bit more to
prove which is it either hits
a strict vertex or
it's tangent to seams.
And this basically
follows the same argument
that if you hit something other
than a strict vertex or a seam,
you would have positive
curvature where
you shouldn't, basically.
So I'll just leave it at that.
I think that's
enough for the proof.
You get the idea why
creases can't exist.
Any questions about that?
I have few more questions.
One question is, can we see
more examples of rolling belts?
And in some sense,
this example is
an example of a rolling belt.
So D-forms, you take
two, say, ellipses.
And the seam that connects
them is a rolling belt.
And this is an illustration
of the rolling action.
As you change, which point
glues to which point?
Let's say I fix this point.
I can glue to this one or
to this one or to this one
or to this one.
And then I zip around.
That's the rolling of the belt.
More generally,
I'll draw a picture.
More generally, a rolling
belt from the viewpoint
of a gluing tree is that
you have basically it's
like a conveyor belt
like at the airport
or on a tank or something.
You've got treads here
and it's going to roll.
So if I mark a point, let's
say I mark this point.
And I roll it around
this way a little bit,
this point maybe
stays stationary
and I end up with
something like this.
And what that means is whatever
this guy glued to over here
is now over here.
So we're changing the gluing.
This guy's now getting glued
to some point like this
because it kind of rolls around.
So in general,
you're rolling this,
but then you're always just
gluing across this path.
For this to work, every angle
out here must be less than
or equal to 180,
like the material
that's out on the outside.
Remember, the gluing
tree has the outside
of the polygon in here.
The inside of
polygon's out here.
So all the material's
on the outside here.
All of these things must be
less than or equal to 180.
If you can find a path
in your gluing tree
where you've got less than
180 material all around you,
then you can do this rolling.
And no matter how you roll,
and then just glue across,
you will still have a valid
gluing, a valid Alexandrov
gluing.
So that's what rolling
belts look like in general.
We see them all over the
place with these D-forms.
The simple example
I showed in class
was when you take a rectangle,
you glue into a cylinder.
And now up here, I've
got a rolling belt.
Because if you look
at the sides here,
I've got actually exactly
180 degrees of material
all around the belt.
And so I could
collapse it like this
or I could collapse
it-- let me tape it.
A little hard to
hold everything.
If you look at this belt, I
could collapse it like this.
Or I could roll it a little
bit and classify like that.
bit, collapse it like that.
Roll it a little more.
Collapse it like that.
All of these are valid
gluing because they're always
gluing 180 to 180.
And that's what
rolling belts are.
Does the broken applet work now?
I don't know why
it wasn't working.
Probably some conflict
with suspension
or just the Java
installation was bad.
But here it is.
It's freely available online.
You draw your graph.
It's a little hard to just use.
It's hard to draw
an exciting example.
Here I'll a draw a tetrahedron
because that's simple.
In this case, it's abstract,
so all of these edges
are unit lengths.
It's kind of like TreeMaker.
You separately
specify the lengths.
Then you say Compute.
And it will find, in this
case, it's a tetrahedron,
an equilateral.
A regular tetrahedron
is a little hard
to see because we've got
either a weird field of view
or a lot of perspective here.
But this is a
regular tetrahedron.
You can verify that by say
making some of these lengths
longer.
I'll make three of them five.
So then this is like a pyramid.
Of course, we're just
essentially applying
Cauchy's rigidity theorem here
and say, oh, this uniquely
assembles into this
spiky tetrahedron.
You could, in principle,
drawn an across here
with the appropriate gluing.
It's a little tricky
to draw in because you
have to also triangulate.
It'd be hard to do from
scratch to compute gluings.
But in theory, especially
if you use software
to compute the gluings
and compute shortest
path in a glued
polygon-- which we'll
be getting more to next class.
Next lecture is about
algorithms for finding gluings.
Then computing shortest paths.
Then you could use that as
input to this software which
will then compute what
the 3D polyhedron is.
So that's the Alexandrov
implementation.
This is by, I think, a student
of Bobenko and Izmestiev.
One quick question
about-- running out
of time-- about
the nonconvex case.
So we're doing all this work
about making convex surfaces.
I said nonconvex
case is trivial.
In a sense, the decision
problem is trivial.
It's not an easy
theorem to prove.
And aha, taped it up.
It follows from what's called
the Burago-Zalgaller theorem.
And it says that if you tap
any polyhedral metric-- so that
means you take a polygon,
you glue it however you want.
You could even add boundary.
Pick any polyhedron metrics, so
you take any polygon and glue
it however you want.
It could have handles.
It could be a doughnut.
It could be whatever.
Then it has an isometric
polyhedral realization in 3D.
So there is a way-- so
we're doing it abstractly.
We're gluing stuff together.
It's kind of topologically.
We don't know what we're doing.
But then there is a way
to actually embed it
as a polyhedral surface
in 3D without stretching
any of the lengths.
So it's a folding of
the piece of paper.
It could have creases in
it, will have actually
tons of creases in it.
And it has exactly the
right-- it connects
all the things you want
it to connect together.
It's kind of crazy.
Furthermore, it could
be self-crossing.
But if your surface
is either orientable--
so it doesn't have any cross
caps or Mobius strips in it--
or it has boundary,
then there's even
a way to do without crossings.
So that's basically all
the cases we care about.
You could glue this together
into a sphere or into a disk
or into a torus or
two-handled torus or whatever.
No matter what you
do, there is a way
to embed it in 3D as a
presumably nonconvex very
creased surface.
This is a hard to prove.
If you're familiar
with Nash's embedding
theorem about embedding
Riemannian surfaces,
it uses a bunch of techniques
from there called spiraling
perturbations,
which I don't know.
And one description I read
calls the resulting surfaces
"strongly corrugated," which
I think means tons of creases.
It is finitely many creases.
That's the theorem.
There's no bound on them.
As far as I know,
there's no algorithm
to compute this thing.
I've never seen a picture
of them, otherwise,
I'd show it to you.
So lots of open problems
in making this real.
But at least the decision
problem is kind of boring.
You do any gluing.
It will make a nonconvex thing.
To find that thing is
still pretty interesting
question though.
That's it.